i grew up homeless in the wilderness so
this is northern california in the late
70s and through the 80s
where we were living off-grid there was
times like
six years old we're living out by a
stream there's no roads into where we're
at we've got
beams latched up into the trees and
that's where our bedding is at at night
because there's rattlesnake dens i'm six
years old
my brother's four my sisters
like one year old and my mom's pregnant
and and that's the environment i'm
i'm being taught how to capture live
rattlesnakes by hand
because that's the environment i live in
like here's a here's how you
carve a forked stick and this is how you
entice it to strike so that you can
you can capture and pin its neck and
then pick it up and then
hold it and know how to hold and control
this snake while it's wrapping around
your arm with
the only intent in its life at that
point is to kill you
and so you know learning how to manage
your fear because if you don't if you
let fear overtake you you're gonna die
and if you don't respect it and you're
just careless and have no fear
whatsoever you're gonna die like so i
learned these lessons
uh i learned a lot of things in a
different manner
at a very young age so it was
that bring it wasn't always necessarily
homeless like during the school year we
would be closer to
society we might have something it might
just be missing
a shack missing running water or
electricity or both
so it's like you know during the summer
you're filling up a gallon jug down
on the stream and setting it out on a
rock and
letting it heat up through the day so
you can dump it over your head or
you know during the winter it's like in
in oregon where we had
you know snow i'd be out in a couple
feet of snow in the back out the back
door after heating up a pot
you know this is in junior high on the
on the wood on the wood stove so i could
try to
try to clean because i'm getting made
fun of at school because i i smell funny
and that's that's just a different
environment and
when you're what people don't realize
yeah
when i talk about it people will kind of
fantasize about it going man that must
have been amazing
but they missed the piece well as far as
i like the living in the
wilderness and not having you know the
connection with
all the things like we didn't have we
didn't have tv we didn't have radio
we just read books my parents were very
intelligent they just
chose not to be part of society my my
mom was actually going to school to be a
a chemical engineer top of her class my
father was a member of mensa
like we our live the library was
was our friend that's where we read
books by candlelight by flashlight
like consumed mass amount of but what
people don't realize when they kind of
romanticize
this life of you know foraging for food
and hunting animals and living in tents
and growing up in this off grid is
the people that are living there for
non-altruistic reasons
are ones that are away from society
because
you know they beat somebody for you know
to death with a tire iron for twenty
dollars
uh they we had
it's still tough to talk about but i
covered in the scope of the book but i
dealt with
murderers i saved my mother from a
serial killer that tracked her later in
life as well when we got out of prison
we dealt with human trafficking that
directly affected our house as a result
of
uh as a result of police corruption and
so much like
you read my book and it's gonna be like
people be like man
that's crazy go watch the documentary
murder mountain it's on netflix and that
took place
50 miles from where we were at it was
about three hours 50 miles because
it's so so remote and the roads are
windy but you'll see just how much i'm
talking about
people disappearing murderers serial
killers
corruption all this stuff so it was it
was wild we got taken by the state for a
while
and you know we were in northern
california so let's be upfront my
parents were growing weed for a living
that's
they're trying to find a way of making a
life outside of society and so we're up
in the you know the the golden triangle
as they called it which is
kind of what the the murderer mountain
documentary is about but in these remote
uh
areas that were highly prized for
growing marijuana
but once they got us back they decided
to stay out of the drug trade so
we moved to oregon the eastern side of
the state where there's a lot of deserts
and
mountains and is more remote and kind of
got into mining
at that point and just fell back right
in the same kind of living just
staying clean of of you know the drug
trade so that they didn't have a chance
of
losing us again and uh things just kind
of
i i ended up kind of helping i had three
younger sisters and a younger brother
and i was
kind of the one that took care of all of
them when they were out attending the
crops who were in later years mining or
i was helping money and helping with the
kids and then when i left
to go to school which i realized is the
only way out like i'm watching
i'm i'm i'm watching people die around
me i'm watching them go to prison i'm
watching
them succumb to drugs and i'm like i
have to figure a way out of this so
there's no a lot of people put
themselves in this uh you know
burning the bridges mentality was kind
of forced on me there's just no place to
go back to and so
i uh i did really well in school as
valedictorian as a state level athlete
and i got a
really solid scholarship academic to go
to school for a
dual engineering degree and i'll just
shorten the story here but i ended up
taking custody and raising my three
younger sisters because things got
worse at home once i left and like that
stabilizing force that i was in the home
you know i was working and providing
money when i was there
you know all through junior high high
school and
when i left things my my stepfather just
descended into
uh his mental health just deteriorated
to a point my mom
disappeared and i had to i'd just take a
step up so i raised my three younger
sisters
while i pursued my engineering degrees
went on to do my mba i was working
full-time
during that that whole all of that as
well and then
and then all the other stuff happened
after that so
as far as the business success and other
stuff but that's
that's the early years so so yeah i know
a little bit about struggle
like i've had nearly if you talk about
like the
nine major you know things that
traumatize people and affect their
their life i've had eight of them and
probably nine
i just have some uh memory failures in
some other areas and
i don't really feel i need to uh do
hypnosis and kind of explore and bring
back some of those memories so
um yeah yeah i know a little bit about
it
okay well that's a hell of a story
that's sounds like quite a life that you
wouldn't necessarily wish on somebody
but you're successful and how did you
did you manage to avoid resentment for
some of the things you've been through
yeah and you'll you'll see it when you
read like i
i still hold you know my parents in high
regard just
i know what they were trying to do and
like my mother still lives
i mean she showed me some amazing things
she showed me
about perseverance no matter what
the struggle always moving forward and
she chose that really hard life but
i i i got to experience just you know
the trials and tribulations that come
across from it and trying to
keep that together the the unity of
family like we did
everything together um and people don't
realize like it was
us against the world and then the
biggest thing that i
learned is just this this authenticity
this it's more than authenticity it is
it it is doing what you're going to do
being yourself
and creating this own world for yourself
around you
despite what anybody says and living the
way that you want to live
and and and that's that's had a huge
impact on my life i mean that's
that's probably the biggest thing so
those those key attributes
are are really important and i've
rebuilt my relationship with her we have
a
a good relationship i let her uh rebuild
it with my sisters first because that
was the
i was i wasn't resentful so much as
disappointed and she needed because she
kind of left them
and so she once they had kind of
repaired that relationship i'm like okay
you know
it's opening doors for me because i
wanted to be there to support my sisters
first
and so once they they'd rekindle them
and rebuilt that
i stepped in and we've had a you know a
very great relationship now the last
like 20 years or so
15 years uh that it's been
how do you start rebuilding a
relationship with
so with a person who ends up hurting you
by leaving how did you how did you even
start that
yeah so like i said for me it wasn't so
much as
hurting me directly as much as like i
said it was the impact on
that i could have seen that i had on my
on my sisters and that
that's where my priority was